[Music]
welcome to CES where the gadgets robots
and smart lawnmowers have taken over
every year we come to the show to check
out the next big or crazy new pin from a
our glasses to pressed punks here are
some of our favorites as our homes fill
up with more more Internet connected
stuff who's keeping them safe Symantec
is building cybersecurity right inside
this funny-looking Wi-Fi router if the
norton core notice is something
suspicious like malware or even a botnet
attack it can immediately quarantine
your devices and send an alert the
$280.00 router also grades your network
with the security score to help
encourage better practices wondering
what this thing is
it's the willow breast pump I'm not
going to demo it for obvious reasons but
if it works as promised there gonna be a
lot of thankful moths no loud machine
with cords here this all-in-one pump
fits right into a bra and collects up to
four ounces of milk in a leak-proof bag
pair it with your phone and it keeps
track of the milk volume and pumping
time the FDA cleared device will be
available this spring for four hundred
and twenty nine dollars and just when
you thought televisions couldn't get any
thinner the new W series OLED from LG is
basically just wallpaper only as thick
as three stack quarters this TV mounts
to a steel wall plate like it's a giant
refrigerator magnet no gap whatsoever
they did it by removing a separate
backlight layer you'll find on other TVs
and by moving the processor and speakers
to separate box faces and colors on the
sensor packed ball changed to help with
social cues and parents and therapists
can use an app to prioritize the balls
actions based on the child's needs it's
scheduled to sell for six hundred and
ninety dollars this fall how do I look
in these augmented reality glasses while
current a our gear is focused on
industrial use these are eight glasses
from OD
we are pitched at consumers the main
attraction is a 40 degree field of view
HD screen that appears to hover right in
front of your eyes a developer version
of the glasses will debut later this
year
for less than $1000 Open Sesame
the future is hiding in your trash can
thanks to a built-in microphone the
simple human sensor can opens its lid
when it hears your commands close whoa
don't want to chat with your trash wave
your hand above the infrared motion
sensor and it opens its heading to your
kitchen this March starting at $180